it would be a tall order to weave the
galaxy's most feared Sith Lord back in
the Star Wars Episode nine but the dark
side of the force is a pathway to many
abilities some consider to be unnatural
so how exactly might that happen here
are a few ideas George Lucas inserted
Anakin Skywalker is a force ghost in the
final moments of Return of the Jedi
although it's always been assumed that
only Jedi could access this power
Anakin's last-minute switch to the good
guys must have given him just enough
positive mojo to earn a spot beside
obi-wan and Yoda replacing Sebastian
Shaw with a digitally inserted Hayden
Christensen in the special edition still
feels like a gratuitous revision to the
classic film but it does crack the door
open for what might be the most likely
way for Vader to return in episode 9 as
a force ghost played by Christensen
whether offering counsel to Rey as a
Jedi or to kylo Ren is the new supreme
leader of the first order
Anakin could still impact his family
story one last time in the arts of the
force awakens concept art from Episode
seven by Ian McKay portrays Christensen
is anakin appearing as a force ghost
with his face alternating between human
Vistage and the mask of Vader this piece
was created after Abrams came on board
as director so it's entirely possible he
could revisit the concept in Episode
nine watch the Star Wars saga films
enough and soon enough you'll start to
notice that certain aspects of the
movies rhyme with certain plot beats
echoing across all three trilogies
portraits so if they rhyme for example
there's a climactic moment in each of
the first films where a trusted mentor
figure dies unexpectedly Revenge of the
Sith and return of the Jedi both feature
unexpected character reveals of some
kind will the pattern repeat okay so
that's probably a massive stretch but
what good is a fan theory without some
grasping at straws I'm getting too old
for this sort of thing following the
reveal theme episode 9 could feature a
sequence in which a ghostly Vader is
providing counsel to kylo Ren secretly
guiding him toward a decisive loss at
the hands of the resistance only for Ren
to learn the ghost is actually the force
ghost of Luke Skywalker tricking kylo to
help his friends if nothing else it
would be a suitable follow-up to Luke's
promise that he'll see kylo again
the end of the last Jedi in the force
awakens Rey experiences what would later
be termed a force back in which our
contact with Luke's lightsaber gives her
a glimpse of both the past and future of
the Star Wars saga that lightsaber was
Luke's and his father's before him and
now he calls to you filled with
references to Star Wars past and present
this sequence has provided fertile
ground for Star Wars fans speculators a
flashback in episode 9 would offer
another easy way for Abrams to introduce
Darth Vader back into the saga kylo
could get a glimpse of a pivotal moment
in Bader's life through contact with his
helmet or another character could
remember their own encounter with Vader
from the past one piece of old universe
lore that has been reintroduced is the
holocron a small device usually a cube
that can hold training and insights from
either Jedi or Sith when the holocron is
activated the recording is played back
as a hologram similar to Princess Leia
projecting from r2d2 in the original
Star Wars the holocron was introduced in
1991 in the dark empire comic series and
returned to modern continuity in later
comics and the Clone Wars and rebels
television series it's a handy plot
device whether as a MacGuffin to prompt
a Jedi or Sith race across the galaxy or
an easy way to cram in some exposition
through the broadcast of a long-lost
character more interestingly if Vader
recorded his own holocron of sith
insights it's possible kylo Ren might
have discovered it and could replay it
in episode 9 in Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine explains the anakin that dark
Plagueis was a Sith Lord obsessed with
immortality who mastered the ability to
create life through the manipulation of
midi-chlorians Plagueis was once Darth
Sidious Sith master and as soon as
Sidious mastered his own grasp of this
arcane art he murdered Plagueis in his
sleep a single panel in the fortress
Vader storyline from the Darth Vader
comic series connects this Sith legend
to one of the biggest questions in Star
Wars lore the parentage of Anakin
Skywalker we know Anakin's mother wish
me a slave from Tatooine but his father
has always remained a mystery
invaders journey through Mustafa's
mysterious darkside portal he has a
vision of his mother as Palpatine lurks
just over her shoulder manipulating
strange
energies in her womb it's the closest
star wars has come to implying that the
father of Anakin Skywalker is in fact
Emperor Palpatine using the powers he
learned from Darth Plagueis to create
life it's possible this knowledge didn't
die with Palpatine and then he passed it
on somehow either to his apprentice or
with a holocron or other vessel kylos
discovery of such knowledge would set
him on the path to mastering it and
resurrecting his grandfather it's very
clear that episode 9s filmmakers could
bring back Vader if they wanted to but
should they it's a tough question on one
hand this new Star Wars trilogy has
managed to cleverly fold in elements of
the past films and surprising and
resonant ways if they do bring back
Darth Vader it's sure to feel
significant and creatively fulfilling
and if you viewed the total nine film
story of the main line Star Wars films
as the saga of the Skywalker family then
it would make sense for the patriarch to
return one last time and influence the
events surrounding his grandsons rise to
power on the other hand Vader has become
iconic partly because when he does
appear it truly matters take that
sequence in rogue one sure it was a nice
excuse for an extended sequence of Sith
badassery using all of the special
effects and filmmaking skills the crew
had to offer but it was also a
demonstration of Bader's impact on a
moment of key importance to the entire
Star Wars galaxy if he had succeeded the
Death Star plans would have remained in
the Empire's possession and the
burgeoning rebellion might have been
snuffed out his failure had immense
consequences for the story as a whole
ultimately that's the real question fans
should be asking about Darth Vader in
the run-up to episode 9 not whether he
can return to the story but instead what
kind of monumental events could warrant
his reappearance in a galaxy far far
away check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]